le millième but de Pelé c'était il y a
quelques mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est avec sa fille Kelly
Christina 4 ans et sa charmante épouse
Rose-Marie que le Dieu du football se
trouve à Paris
les pellets ont d'ailleurs l'intention
de rester plusieurs jours dans la
capitale et d'y passer même les fêtes de
Noël
[Applaudissements]
pas d'Escorts officiels pour accueillir
le roi mais ses admirateurs tout
simplement
premier rendez-vous à la Porte de
Versailles à l'occasion du Salon de la
compétition comme les grands de ce monde
Pelé à du satisfaire à la conférence de
presse
pour jouer au Paris Saint-Germain était
sérieux effectivement il y a eu des
contacts entre les dirigeants parisiens
et moi-même ils m'ont invité en cette
occasion à porter les couleurs de leur
club mais mon contrat avec Santos
n'était pas terminé et j'ai toujours
exprimé le désir d'achever ma carrière à
Santos le seul club que j'ai connu dans
sa carrière de footballeur
au maximum j'abandonnerai définitivement
mes activités de football
en ce qui concerne d'affaires je compte
surtout développer mon job de relation
publique dans une banque et monter une
manufacture d'articles de sport
madame pellet à Paris
il est aussi à Paris c'est elle qui fera
les vitrines
[Musique]